[Music]  hello to the one and only Christina  Aguilera Christina Aguilera stole the  show on the season 10 premiere of a  RuPaul's Drag Race and she grabs some  headlines backstage on a sister series  untucked you go backstage and it was  going down and go down it did as xtina  revealed secrets about some of her songs  starting with fighter  [Music]  can ask a question so with that about  someone cuz I'm reading the lyrics where  you read him for the back then the  lesser-known track infatuation  [Music]  who does Porto Rican cuz you know I  might be relation I know it was  heartbreaking because I found out he  played for your team not mine  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]